[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINGTING ZHOU: My
name is Tingting Zhou,
and I'm a neuroscientist at
the McGovern Institute at MIT.
Imagine for a second
that you are a mouse,
and you'd really like to
eat a piece of cheese.
But in order to
get the cheese, you
must remember the
color of this light.
You can't forget it, even
if the light turns off.
Right now, your mouse
brain is holding
this important
information in an area
called the prefrontal cortex.
And then when you
have to remember
which light you saw earlier,
you probably guessed correctly.
This is called working memory.
The mice in my lab have
difficulty with working memory.
They have schizophrenia,
a serious brain
disorder that affects the
ability to think clearly.
They cannot remember information
for more than a few seconds
because they have mistakes in
their DNA and their prefrontal
cortex doesn't connect properly
to other parts of the brain.
I'm studying how we can fix the
genes and the abnormal brain
connections associated with
schizophrenia so that all mice
and people can live
a rewarding life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]